[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana hablamos de
personajes históricos y cómo se deben de
conmemorar en el presente a raíz del
bicentenario ahora en francia de la
muerte de napoleón para ello me
acompañan en este estudio la periodista
independiente del hierro nate y
bienvenida de liam jorge morón fundador
de francia hoy corresponsal de todo
noticias en argentina bienvenido a jorge
en plan secar los apuntes y en dúplex
alejandro gómez historiador catedrático
de la universidad de la sorbona buenos
días alejandro es por invitación
memòria històrica y conmemoraciones en
el presente hoy en primera plana
pues la pregunta es complicada que
hacemos con napoleón dos siglos después
de haber dividido al mundo en dos
mitades francia busca el difícil encaje
de una de sus figuras más
representativas en un momento de alto
voltaje político para algunos estadista
visionario creador del estado moderno
para otros prefieren quedarse con sus
sombras misógino belicista y personaje
que restableció la esclavitud la
pregunta es cómo establecer los justos
parámetros de un personaje tan
representativo del pasado de francia en
el momento presente pero sin duda el
debate lo podemos extender a otros
lugares y lo haremos por ejemplo con
otros personajes en américa latina'
antes de preguntarle a mis invitados
repasemos algunas portadas que nos deja
la prensa respecto a este asunto la
revista geo historia el legado de
napoleón controvertido 200 años después
de su muerte también la revista actual
se hace eco en esta portada del asunto
con una pregunta salvador o tirano el
diario español la vanguardia en este
artículo de su corresponsal en parís
trata la cuestión dice napoleón
aún espera juicio en referencia a la
controversia suscitada por este
bicentenario en francia bueno delia como
debe acercarse una sociedad moderna a
una democracia a un personaje que
levanta tantas pasiones que tiene tantos
defensores como detractores pero que no
se puede negar en la historia de un país
como es napoleón totalmente yo creo que
lo principal es contextualizar al
personaje en el momento que surgió
napoleón en la época que surgió es
totalmente diferente al actual
hace poco mencionaste que entre sus
lados oscuros o está la misoginia pero
en ese entonces existía mismo se le
puede decir montesquiu era misógeno
entonces hay que contextualizar para
podemos evaluar con los con la misma
exactamente sería injusto para el
personaje y contraproducente para lo que
o sea ahora se llama la identidad
nacional que simplemente parte de lo que
forma un país un estado una nación
entonces yo creo que principalmente hay
que partir de la contextualización para
comprender mejor la historia
jorge partimos de que conmemorar y
celebrar no significa lo mismo aunque
muchas veces se equivocan nuestros dos
términos conmemorar y celebrar por
supuesto no tienen nada que ver los dos
términos pero hay situaciones y hay
personajes como es el caso lógicamente
de napoleón que no se pueden no
conmemorar lo mismo en otras situaciones
históricas como los genocidios pero es
cierto que tomando lo que decía de él ya
es un personaje tan rico y con dos
facetas tan distintas que creo que en
los términos de hoy no se puede más que
tomar aquello el lado positivo las
sombras y lo el lado negativo y decir
construir ese presente porque es
innegable napoleón para la historia de
francia y parte también de europa porque
incluso muchísimos países toman un apoyo
como un referente a nivel mundial y si
esto es esto sirve para construir y
comprender el presente y ver incluso el
futuro claro porque no conmemorar lo
significarían negar la historia pero al
mismo tiempo hay que conmemorar lo
exponiendo esas esas partes de sombras
que muchas veces la historia también ha
de edulcorado no
exactamente yo creo que la relectura de
la historia no necesariamente es algo
negativo o peligroso para la identidad
nacional yo creo que la identidad
nacional no es algo fijado en el tiempo
es algo que evoluciona según la sociedad
y las costumbres yo creo que se le puede
hacer una relectura más sincera y
transparente a napoleón y van a salir
tanto las cosas buenas como las
negativas vamos a preguntar a nuestro
historiador de catedrático en la
universidad de la sorbona alejandro
gómez porque claro el debate estos días
de cómo conmemorar a napoleón
impregna toda toda francia sin duda y se
debe decidir qué lugar ocupa exactamente
en nuestra memoria colectiva el señor
gómez como se debe conmemorar una figura
de este calibre 200 años después de su
muerte en la isla de santa elena
conmemorar
cada época tiene su forma de conmemorar
el pasado yo como historiador la verdad
es que
sabría cómo como no se debe conmemorar
no puede conmemorar se como si fuera un
gran hombre político y militar del siglo
19 como como sugería carla del
investigador escoceses sino una manera
evidentemente contemporánea las
percepciones de nuestra época y las
necesidades de conmemorar de estar
porque están muy asociadas a
sensibilidades actuales no pienso por
ejemplo en el movimiento blanc lives
matter que está fomenta toda la
sensibilidad anti racial o anti racista
que fomenta una crítica a la figura de
napoleón como restablece un personaje
restableció la esclavitud
y también el auge del feminismo no de
una gran crítica en torno al código
civil que reduce nuevamente la mujer
aunque la formaliza la incapacidad
jurídica de la mujer no yo pienso
muertos a estos sectores de la población
hay otros sectores que tienen visiones
distintas y que quizá son conmemoradas
deberíamos tener una visión
conmemorativa mucho más amplia más
holística de
esta figura que a fin de cuentas es un
ser humano que sí tuvo un destino como
se dice aquí en francia improbable un
tipo que viene un corzo bajito que se
burlaban de los cadetes en la en la
escuela en la escuela militar y es un
tipo que producto de la revolución
francesa solo hay que olvidarlo no el
tipo llega a lo alto en una ganancia
algunos sectores para restablecer el
orden y luego también está pasando lo
que pasa
y bueno es capaz de lo digamos de
grandes cosas pero también de grandes
barbaridades hablamos del tema del
restablecimiento de la esclavitud no
también como la de las atrocidades en
sus campañas militares el caso en el
caso español fue un individuo cuando los
ejércitos en egipto y así no yo logre de
esa manera
cumplir con las necesidades del presente
pero también pensar en otras necesidades
otros sectores de la sociedad no sé si
quieren añadir otros elementos porque a
mí lo que me encanta es como fascina la
figura de napoleón 200 años después de
muerto y qué cantidad de pasiones desata
aquí en francia supongo en otros lugares
también pero aquí en francia por
supuesto pero que no se pueden negar
además es un personaje clave de la
historia de francia pero además un
extracto uno de los estrategas a nivel
mundial me parece más representativo es
un fenómeno podríamos decirlo y hay algo
muy importante que lo dijiste que
buscarlo también lo dijo delia y es el
hecho de que cada cada país creo ha
tenido sus ídolos pero esos ídolos
también tienen dos facetas dos caras es
normal son humanos tienen sus sombras
tienen sus luces y personajes históricos
tienen luces y sombras lo contrario
sería un análisis simple no realmente
totalmente entonces
no por eso hay que creo que hay que
considerarlos con con esos componentes
pero sobre todo no olvidarlos ni negar
los hacia la historia de cada nación y
en el caso de napoleón yo creo que él
tiene múltiples facetas general de gran
renombre y historia
trayectoria hombre político hombre que
vivió una gran pasión con josefina que
escribían mil cartas de amor personaje
histórico como poco rico por eso también
se ha visto mucho en el cine en las
artes la representación de él si se
encuentra la por ejemplo el libro el
príncipe anotado por napoleón se puede
ver también que tenía un humor muy ácido
una inteligencia muy sagaz cosa que sea
ese ese se junta mucho con la ideología
lo que se tiene pensado de los franceses
yo creo que es imposible de negar el
legado con el personaje y lo que
representa hasta la actualidad de
napoleón en francia
no creen que el problema es que muchas
veces los políticos la coyuntura
política actual hace relecturas del
pasado para apropiarse la y sacar rédito
en el momento actual
con este tipo de personajes pasa con
napoleón pero podemos irnos otros casos
que al general de gaulle puede pasar
en sus países puede pasar con perón en
argentina pues con muchos personajes que
al final son se hacen relecturas con de
coyuntura política del momento y siempre
con unos fines de capitalizar esos
personajes jorge pues todo lo que creo
que también existe en un tal vez en un
pensamiento muy profundo es porque no
hay personajes que sirven como
inspiración a los políticos de hoy y no
solamente caso de napoleón tenemos
muchos casos acá en francia que sirven
actualmente a quienes están en el poder
con las cargas del gobierno y que sirven
para inspirarnos pero efectivamente hay
que tomar con pinzas porque son momentos
históricos distintos y que determinadas
frases a veces sirven para justificar
momentos de la historia contemporánea
entonces bueno hay que saberlo utilizar
y eso a veces no siempre cabe bien en la
ciudadanía y también se busca polarizar
la sociedad
los que están a favor los que están en
contra también para capitalizar un voto
y dependiendo del candidato que porte
ese mensaje yo creo que hay que tener
mucho cuidado porque ahí lo que se hace
es acabar con lo que es una identidad
nacional para solamente con fines
electorales yo creo que eso también
tiene en cuenta vamos a preguntar a
nuestro historiador alejandro omedes de
la sorbona que legado deja en la francia
actual el gran personaje histórico que
es napoleón pero la figura de la polera
en francia
es una figura cuyas gloria son
recordadas lo vemos en la vida cotidiana
los volúmenes son monumentos en todos
los toponímicos que hay hay estaciones
de trenes arcos etcétera es uno de los
arcos construidos por el mismo la
escuela carrousel del louvre etcétera no
es la plaza don no era el monumento
austerlitz pero quizás una se olvida es
la ruina no sacamos en nada en una
visión de gloria y de ruina y esa ruina
se olvida por la por la mitificación del
personaje no y hoy vamos a todos estos
temas
que hable anteriormente hay también otra
otra impronta otro legado si se quiere
con el siglo 19 con el surgimiento del
movimiento partidista
que después va a llevar la atrapó león
30 amigos decididos al poder y que va a
tener una influencia muy grande
incluyendo por ejemplo el caso desde el
pari haussmaniano que va a tener tanto
impacto en la el urbanismo y la
arquitectura tanto en europa como en
américa latina
la misma código civil tuvo una
influencia muy grande más allá de las
fronteras del hexágono franceses y vemos
cómo se expanden las colonias a las
colonias francesas pero también otras
partes de américa latina- nuevamente
pensemos en el andrés bello como su
código inspirado en parte en el francés
tuvo el pleno 55 tuvo un impacto
importante en otros países américa
latina y otro aspecto ya a nivel más
europeo de la impronta de la flota
napoleónica me parece que sería como
marca la los espacios políticos en
europa
napoleón un directa o indirectamente fue
transmisor por un lado del estado
moderno no estamos en la época de la
formación de los estados nacionales y
vemos como directamente a través de la
de la formación del reino de italia
tienen aún ya tiene la bandera del
federal a la pole on que prestó el aval
de la primera materia italia viene de
allí y compitió también indirectamente a
través de el odio que genera
en alemania de alguna manera el
nacionalismo alemán nace
contra la invasión napoleónica no es
entonces bueno estos son todos esos
elementos por supuesto que hay otros no
pero es muy diversa y que no se limita
solamente a al emperador no muy
interesante todo lo que nos muestra nos
cuenta nuestro historiador les voy a
preguntar partiendo del ejemplo de
napoleón por otros casos por otros
personajes polémicos y controvertidos
también en américa latina pero va a ser
la vuelta de pausa
nuestros equipos recogen los testimonios
de los que viven la noticia una mirada
diferente a la actualidad
vídeos que no verá en ningún otro sitio
los observadores en france 24 y france
24 puntocom
[Música]
france24 punto com está disponible en
cuatro idiomas artículos reportajes
noticias internacionales continuamente
todas nuestras ediciones para ver de
nuevo y el canal en directo 24 horas los
7 días intuitivo rápido y en cuatro
lenguas france24 puntocom liberté
égalité actualice
continuamos aquí en primera plana de
radio france internacional y de france
24 esta semana analizando el legado que
deja en la francia actual un personaje
muy controvertido como es napoleón a
raíz de la celebración del bicentenario
de su muerte nos preguntamos cómo debe
encajar la memoria histórica a
personajes de la talla de napoleón
hablábamos de napoleón en la primera
parte y les pregunto ahora si hay otros
casos que quieran rescatar por ejemplo
de américa latina' de su país jorge que
puedan con los que podamos trazar
ciertos paralelismos en cuanto a la
controversia del legado en el presente
de la memoria histórica
bueno como vos lo cité al comienzo
carlos creo que uno de los más
emblemáticos es el caso de perón
desertado por muchos y capas mi
idolatrado por una gran gran mayoría de
argentinos el caso también de podría
decir incluso de san martín pasa que san
martín es incluso uno de los diría el
gen argentino por excelencia porque
claro liberar tres países pero a costa
también de muchas cosas un excelente
estratega también
podría decirlo incluso llamas pero en
francia otro personaje por ejemplo el de
luis 16 el rey sol también qué opulencia
por un lado pero por otro lado también
alguien que genera muchísimos puntos
positivos y negativos de acuerdo
desacuerdo creo que es otro otro
personaje histórico que es innegable
pero es que tienes está está sobre todo
esos dos y el tercero para hacer
referencia también algo que mencionaba
delia es el caso de rosas que genera
también unitarios federales y bueno
venerado idolatrado y después nuevamente
condenado por por toda la ciudadanía
argentina no esté pensando que también
en el caso de francia respecto a la
política actual sería el general de
gaulle no que es el típico caso el
típico ejemplo que todos los políticos
hacen referencia a él e intentan
apropiarse de ciertas de ciertos legados
del general de gaulle del ya personas
que quiere rescatar totalmente como
comentaba con juan manuel de rosas es lo
interesante es que en su momento este
personaje fue catalogado como tirano
como
como un gobernador porque fue gobernador
de buenos aires- general brigadier
general
y después con el tiempo en los años 30
40 cuando hubo la montada del fascismo
fue recuperado es decir lo sacaron de
esa de esa caja que tenían de tirano y
lo pusieron como héroe nacional
actualmente vuelven a hacer otra
relectura pero lo interesante acá es que
se puede ver que la identidad nacional
no es un relato fijo en el tiempo sino
que evoluciona según las sociedades y
también según los los partidos políticos
y los y los jefes políticos que estén en
el gobierno se toman ciertos personajes
para apoyar ciertas características o
para criticar ciertas cosas estos
debates acalorados que estamos teniendo
ahora en francia con el bicentenario de
napoleón no sé si también se reproducen
en sus países con parámetros parecidos o
no sé no sé si piensan que francia tiene
incomodidad para mirar a su pasado o que
si va en el adn de los franceses este
tipo de polémicas
no sé cómo lo ven
hay una cierta una cierta incomodidad
por el lado de francia digamos de
aceptar un poco también esa parte
histórica lo que venimos hablando es ese
pasado sí haciendo referencia a lo que
hablamos al comienzo de la conmemoración
pasa algo similar por ejemplo en la
argentina con la figura de cristóbal
colón por ejemplo que en algún momento
durante muchos años se lo vio de una
manera hoy se lo conmemora
de otra pero volviendo efectivamente a
lo de francia creo que el pasado
colonialista que es innegable genera
cierta molestia y eso sería también
bueno de tomarlo como como bien y de
aceptarlo porque como digo es innegable
para la historia del país y para
continuar mejorando en el futuro
si estoy estoy de acuerdo pero sobre
todo yo creo que se toca fibras
muy sensibles en la sociedad justo en
esto en estos momentos complicados que
se están viviendo donde la sociedad en
general está pasando una etapa de
sentimiento de débil debilidad tocar las
grandes figuras logra el gran pasado
francés causa un temor pero al mismo
tiempo yo creo que una relectura de la
historia no necesariamente va en contra
de lo que es la grandeza de la francia o
la identidad nacional al contrario
buscar una relectura un poco más justa
de la historia del pasado puede crear
bases más sólidas para las sociedades
futuras para generaciones futuras las
controversias en este asunto vienen
derivadas muchas veces porque la
coyuntura política como comentábamos del
momento intenta reapropiarse para su
relato de un acontecimiento de un
personaje vamos a preguntar a nuestro
historiador a alejandro gómez desde la
universidad de la sorbona como puede la
labor del historiador contribuir a todo
este debate contribuir a la sociedad
intentando desligar los relatos
políticos de los hechos documentados
históricamente 'alejandro'
pero para nada más que dices tenemos una
responsabilidad social es decir queremos
informar a nuestros conciudadanos del
pasado para evitar que caigan en las
trampas de las manipulaciones las
manipulaciones históricas que utilizan
ciertas ideologías todas las ideologías
tienen un componente un componente
histórico por otro lado la muchos
entrenadores que han pasado convertirse
en especialistas de memoria pero
recordemos que la memoria no es en sí
misma una ciencia y que tenemos
choqueado por historia haciendo cosas
muy valiosas de historiadores que no lo
están haciendo a veces también en la
casa américa latina bueno un apoyo me
parece a mí que no es un personaje que
genera conflictos de memoria no hay
realmente un personaje que valdría la
pena realmente rememorar lo en américa
latina por eso es muy importante
el tema por ejemplo de la deriva looks
de este magistrado civil a convertirse a
un emperador tiene consecuencias fuertes
en américa latina
el tema de la restauración de la
esclavitud no se queda solamente en
shanghai del agua
hay un impacto importante sobre todo en
los países en el espacio caribeños no le
dan el siglo de las luces carpetilla
para que sepan de lo que estoy hablando
no
más polémicos son los casos de esto al
colon de ese monstruo indigenista que
dibujará algunos
de las postas que tenemos tres
indigenistas contra una figura que fue
usada para combatir el colonialismo y
que fue figura también de orgullo
para los internos americanos por ejemplo
argentina en los que los estados unidos
y ahí los historiadores me parece a mí
que estamos llamados si es que nos
llamamos por supuesto a jugar un rol
mediador se si quiere para aportar
soluciones
por otro lado hay vender y otros
personajes no los cables inicial de la
figura de oliva de nuestras personas que
tenían bolívar izquierda de bolívar de
derechas muy identificados incluso de
nacimiento a lo que es venezuela hoy
una república fundamentalista he llevado
el culto oliver otra hora de carrera
damas a niveles verdaderamente
impresionantes un mártir revolucionario
y martín del exilio cubano en miami el
che guevara del diario de la motocicleta
del guerrillero romántico también el
asesino de la cabaña o sea como
y ahí es donde los historiadores yo creo
que es importante que intervenga no
porque realmente los astros tenemos
nosotros no después son los políticos y
los que se encargan de políticas
públicas de memoria de intentar
derrumbar los mitos y tratar de de
informar a los ciudadanos a fin de
cuentas
precisamente de eso de eso se trata que
importante la labor de los historiadores
sin duda pero cuando hacemos frente a
figuras como fijaos los nombres que
estaba editando alejandro colom el che
guevara napoleón son grandes personajes
históricos que claro tienen luces y
sombras tienen de todo dentro de ellos y
en la sociedad de la inmediatez del
twitter del de la cultura del titular
rápido
no sé si tiempo para digerir este tipo
de planteamientos que deben tener muchos
matices y debe tener mucho trasfondo no
sé si esta sociedad está preparada para
o al menos hacia donde baja sería
interesante saber antes de compartir a
veces una frase antes de compartir un
hecho bien tener en cuenta de que
personas que estamos hablando porque a
veces se cita algo se cita alguien muy
rápido sólo por
aprovechar ese momento que ahora bien
con tal situación con alguien que dijo a
alguien en su momento se envía y claro
se olvida a veces de el contexto y eso a
veces no no pasa siempre nos gusta a
todo el mundo por eso es importante
tomarse un poco el tiempo pero es cierto
lo que vos decís carlos estamos en una
vorágine digital todo el tiempo que pasa
y ya muchos ni siquiera prestan atención
a lo que pasan por la red no leen y así
así así se toma es que intentar aplicar
la justicia histórica o intentar
explicar un legado con luces y sombras a
personajes como napoleón o como el che
guevara en una red social como twitter a
mí me parece imposible pero yo es por
eso la necesidad de una relectura más
justa de la historia para que eso sea
aplicado en los colegios y yo no tenga
una base a la cual sea más fácil de
aceptar una historia real no tan
idealizada o parcializada y que después
uno no comience a creer cualquier cosa
porque lo leen en facebook o en twitter
por eso es necesario esta relectura no
es simplemente cosa de la modernidad y
cambiar todas las bases es necesario
porque la sociedad
y el relato tiene que evolucionar con
ella y pese a todo no creen que ya es de
por sí un éxito en este tipo de momentos
como un bicentenario que se hable del
tema que quizá la amnesia sea el peor
enemigo jorge
no creo que finalmente la memoria
siempre está creo que siempre hay hay
cosas que sé que se retienen que se
mantienen y me parece que es
es bueno es el capital comprender como
dice de él ya que ciertas ciertas cosas
de la historia determinados personajes
es más que importante y creo que sirven
muchas veces para hacernos recordar
algunas cosas muchas para no repetirlas
y otras para tomarlas
para lo que viene no creen que el debate
sobre memoria histórica debatidas oa
partir de grandes personajes como el
caso de napoleón podemos hablar de otros
y por supuesto ayuda a construir
sociedades democráticamente más sanas
que tengan menos miedo o más elementos
para mirar al pasado de una forma más
sana
d'elía totalmente una sociedad sobre
todo más inclusiva donde solamente donde
no solamente un relato idealizado
predomine yo creo que es fundamental y
sobre todo en estos tiempos donde hay
tantas cosas que están cambiando también
tiene que modernizar seguir por el buen
camino lo que lo malo sería que sea
utilizado por partidos políticos
para capitalizar votos porque ahí sería
cambiar un relato por otro relato que no
necesariamente se apega a lo ocurrido a
la historia los políticos también
cumplen una función en todo esto porque
deben en momentos históricos como
bicentenarios hay el político es el que
ayuda a crear este tipo de espacios pero
también está la figura del historiador
está la figura está la sociedad civil
están los profesores estamos los medios
de comunicación es decir la memoria
histórica se construye a través de todos
los actores sociales múltiples matices
carlos y esto es como una es como una
ensalada en donde hay que ver que ese
todo es muy difícil es muy fina la línea
a veces puede ser puede ser no no no es
fácil delimitar los caminos y sobre todo
cuando hablamos de personajes tan tan
tan comprometidos con la historia que
que forjaron destinos de naciones
entonces efectivamente como sí creo que
lo importante es que cada uno desde
nuestro rol
en este caso como periodista tenemos que
conocer lo máximo y estar lo más
informados posibles para saber de quién
y cómo se habla simplificar la historia
porque la historia es no es simple no se
puede hacer en un tuit
explicar la historia nos quedamos con
esa última frase la historia no se puede
hacer en un simple tweet
a veces cuesta no a hacer todos los
matices pero son necesarios para
enfrentarse a la realidad muchísimas
gracias jorge delia alejandro desde la
sorbona y a todos ustedes hasta la
próxima semana quien en primera plana
gracias